Coca
Cola was going to cure morphine
addiction.
Bubble wrap was supposed to be a
trendy new textured wallpaper
and YouTube was going to be the
premiere video dating app.
More often, failed products don't
lead to accidental successes,
but they're nevertheless an
essential feature of capitalism.
It was Karl Marx who set out to
bring production under conscious
control, correcting for the anarchic
forces of the free market.
But it turned out that anarchy,
risk taking and the freedom to try
out wild ideas is the
only process that leads to
successful innovation
because nobody can predict consumer
tastes.
A doll that grows breasts, a hula
chair for office workers, a virtual
reality glove that hit the market in
1989, these
and other commercial flops
are on display at the Museum of
Failure in Washington.
We are very much trying to have fun
with this exhibit.
So people like to make fun of the
fact that we are on the site of a
failed gem.
Joanna Guttman is one of the
organizers of the exhibit.
It's the brainchild of Dr. Samuel
West. He is the curator
of the show. And he realized
that the most successful companies
were those that had a high
failure rate.
So he started to explore this
concept of failure because everyone
loves to talk about success.
No one likes to talk about failure
when in fact failure is a much
better teacher than successes.
The subway is actually a perfect
example, because some people will
say, Well, why would you call the
subway a failure?
The expectation with the Segway
was that entire city infrastructures
would be built around Segways
and people would use it as a mode
of transportation.
But today, we really use subways.
I mean, we all think of that movie
mall cop ride and
those tourist tours.
That's essentially where they've
been relegated to.
Meet new growing up skipper.
He's two dolls in one
because when you turn her arm, you
can make her change instantly from a
little girl to a tall, slender
teenage doll, which is something you
can't do.
It's such a like, creepy thing
that she, like, develops breasts and
gets two dolls in one.
There could not have been any women
at that table. Right.
I think that and the pregnant Barbie
came out around the same time.
So it was like, who was thinking
about this?
Know, it's bizarre.
So there definitely is a tone
deafness sometimes in
marketing.
There are like quite a few products
in here that are like, quote
unquote, before their time.
You have something very similar that
it looks like VR goggles, but it's
obviously obviously not virtual
reality. Right?
Right. Yeah.
Sometimes there are marketing
reasons why something is marketed
poorly and that that leads to
the product's failure.
The discreet sanitary solution.
For your urgent relief.
Guys, how many times has this
happened to you?
Come on. You know you can't hold it
in that long.
Don't worry.
I've got the perfect gift.
It comes with a channel and a
piercing. Sometimes it's
just a timing issue.
But those things kind of pave the
way for how see our products.
Exactly.
So we actually have Google Glass,
which is great, because
nobody would consider Google a
failure as a company, even though
not every product sort of hit the
mark. But people are now saying,
number one, a new Google Glass is
coming out.
We actually had a poster of it at
the New York show where somebody
said, stay tuned.
They work at Google and a new one is
coming out.
And it was anonymous.
So
we have some big issues to deal
with. If we're only going to go with
safe choices or things that we know
that absolutely will work, we
probably are going to end up with
nothing. So we want to solve
big problems. We're going to have to
try. And sometimes the technology
like with the Nintendo glove,
which was very...
People were super excited about it
when it came out, but it had all
these buttons that really didn't do
anything but the same technology
was used for the Wii, which was a
very big commercial success.
So sometimes the same technology is
used also for a
following product.
But tech companies in general are
really good at sort of learning
from their mistakes.
And I don't want to really even call
it mistakes, but learning from
through trial and error and taking
in that feedback.
We are trying to provoke a
conversation about failure,
about success, about innovation.
The museum also has a section
devoted to Elon Musk, who
love him or hate him, from PayPal to
SpaceX, from Tesla to StarLink,
is one of the most successful
entrepreneurs of our time.
But that has a lot to do with his
willingness to take wild risks.
Failure must be an option if
failure is not an option.
There are a lot of extremely
conservative choices, and
you may get something even
worse, like in aviation, things
may go backwards.
He's just really pushing that
envelope all the time, and he makes
us think he's provocative, which
we are trying to be.
So we definitely want to encourage
people to take meaningful risks.
I also think that we live in a time
where social media amplifies
everything, and I think young people
have this real fear of
failing because it's going to follow
me forever or it's going to seem
maybe bigger than it is because it
is on social media.
So we're trying to really sort of
make people more comfortable with
this idea that not everything is
going to work out the way we planned
or the way we had wanted.
If we're always going to be safe and
take the safe route so that
we almost can guarantee
success, then we're not
going to solve big problems
and address situations
because we're not taking any risks
and then we don't innovate and we
don't progress.
There are catastrophic failures
happening all around us
and we're so much richer because of
it.